[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to sidetrack
your sci-fi tv and movie channel and i
was looking at myself then i forgot to
look at the camera
very professional as always
loads of you in today so let's crack on
oh by the way lovely sunny day here in
the uk if it's a lovely sunny day for
you wherever you are give us a shout out
because i think this might be the nicest
day of the year so far which is always
good put me in a good mood anyway
so
i'm here to tell you about the meetings
that happened at mgm last week so
mgm movies their headquarters is in
beverly hills california
and there was big meetings a summit
basically between mgm and amazon the big
executives for these meetings
now
here we go everybody in is in hello
everybody
right so
we'll get to stargate in a minute
but
these meetings were really interesting
because it was the big executives
between mgm and amazon it's the first
time they've met since the sale has gone
through
now
the first few days of this meeting
basically from the 4th of april most of
that week were very much boring business
meetings it was always talking about
projections for things and
money and structure and all this boring
crap that to be honest i don't even know
where they sit through
but then at the end of last week so
around the seventh they did start
talking about
loads of things sj is going to make it
let's see
malasi has said that sga and sgu will
have some sort of conclusion in the new
series so his fingers crossed um but
around the 7th of april they did start
talking about upcoming upcoming even mgm
products
so they had long meetings about the
samaritan the new sliced stallone movie
um about the tomb raider sequel that's
an orient production and a movie called
dark harvest which is a um a graphic
novel horror based on a
graphic novel um these projects they got
to see some um preliminary edits they
got to see an early screening apparently
of the samaritan
and they talked about projects that were
up and coming about to be released or to
be released this year
then
um early the week just started on the
8th of april they started talking about
up-and-coming projects so projects that
aren't currently out there
but
are just about ready
so some of the projects they talked
about
um on the 12th and 13th of april were a
robocop sequel
if it's like the last robocop movie
i i will punch myself in my private
parts before i watch it it was awful the
actor that they have to play robocop
doesn't have to be anybody famous
even when wella did it back in the day
they had to have a bit where his helmet
came off and he saw his face because
he's the actor she got to his face the
last guy that did it was really good in
hannah but he was crap in robocop and
again they had to show his face for
loads of periods of time because he's
probably in his contract robocop has got
his thing he's a very specific character
and that film really is something i was
really really looking forward to and it
was terrible
if they do do a sequel i said do do
it should needs to be a hard reboot for
me just forget that that terrible movie
michael keaton was great in it to be
fair but forget that robocop movie
happened and just do a better version
i'd like to even see a sequel from the
original you know robocop 2 sort of
thing um but anyway
war games again apparently was discussed
now this has actually gone from rumor to
early production there is apparently um
somebody is heading up the production at
the moment a team is being put together
to really start seriously looking at a
war games movie
and yes stan i did say do do
cues dog ever
so and war games has gone from rumor to
very very early production and so we'll
see why that happens i think that will
be probably announced very shortly
um
the outer limits is about to return
so
hopefully
i actually quite like the robocop tv
show as well it was quite good um so uh
that that never quite went as far as it
should have done it should have done it
i think they've got another series i
think that would have really really good
it started brilliantly really dark and
gritty um
so the ads limits is about to return as
well i think that's pretty exciting this
is a tv series that really bounces
backwards and forwards
it's you know it comes back every so
often it's about to come back again i
think it's good timing for that there's
a movie called exoplanet which is going
to be a big sci-fi movie um
a little bit confusing because i've been
told two or three different things from
the sources and the people i speak to
one guy said it's actually going to be
an animated movie and somebody else said
it's um more of a it is going to be live
action but with a lot of cgi so i don't
know maybe avatar sort of
way of doing it i don't know but um
all i was told about this movie this
exoplanet movie by the guy i speak to
that knows a little bit about it he
wouldn't tell me anything about it all
other than and i quote him here you're
gonna freaking love it but he didn't say
freaking
so let's see what happens with that one
piece of news that's not sci-fi
is that apparently they're looking at
remaking the roadhouse movie with
patrick swayze without patrick swayze
obviously because he's not with us
anymore
but apparently a remake of the roadhouse
movie
what the hell are going to do with that
i have no idea
um but let's see
now
old man makes a good point here it'd be
nice if we discussed original movies
rather than all these reboots well
exoplanet is an original movie and so is
um dark harvest and so it's the
samaritan but obviously when a reboot is
is rumored those rumors tend to go
around a little bit quicker than
projects that
maybe are original and that's just sad
but it's just the way it is so these are
the rumors they get talked about so
they're the rumors that get back to me
through the sources that i have the work
in and around mgm
now first bit of big news
that's come out
again i'm getting to the stargate in a
minute i promise but
2001 a space odyssey now i told you a
couple of weeks ago that mgm were really
seriously looking at doing a reboot of
the 2001 space odyssey it would be a
hard reboot of the original serie of the
original book in the original movie
um there has been an update on that
apparently somebody
in one of these executive meetings has
made the suggestion of why don't we do a
series
um my initial reaction was oh god but
this wouldn't be like a network series
where we have to do 22 episodes it would
be a stream in series so 10 episodes
very high budget very high um value
so 2001 a space odyssey a series if they
do something like the first years of
westworld i didn't particularly enjoy
the second series westworld i thought it
went off the tracks a bit but the first
series was excellent if they do
something along those lines i think a
2001 specialized series could be great
and they could go into um the other
books as well so i i think that's that's
got legs and then today how do you do a
reboot if it's not really a reboot do a
series so let's see what happens with
that
the other big news though is that they
seriously spent about an afternoon
apparently on the tuesday talking about
space balls the movie the search for
more money space balls too this is
now gone again from a rumor to or what
could we do to genuinely seriously
talking about should we do this
um to me i think it's a bit of a
no-brainer because star wars is so
massively popular at the moment that
having a project that takes the mick and
pokes fun in it
seems like the simplest thing in the
world to me but again i'm wondering why
don't they do a series a short series
very much like on the mandalorian sort
of style you know um
i i love this i would love to watch
baseballs again it's one of my favorite
movies i watched it last week um for the
first time in about 10 years if they
make spaceport i will literally be
the first in the queue to watch it i
would love it
but
let's get on starting because there were
some rumors about stargate um
it is i am getting onto it sorry nothing
i i promise here's the stargate update
right i was hoping that these meetings
would give us some clarity
they would maybe even god forbid
get a green light we could have even got
an official announcement before the 25th
um of july when the you know the 25th
anniversary um stargate is the 27th of
july i think actually um but the 25th
anniversary of stargate but it actually
seems that instead of getting some
clarity there's been more confusion
so the update is as such
there are still
voices
within amazon and apparently mgm this is
the first time i've actually heard
rumors that there are voices from mgm
executives as well
that they're not sure about brad right's
project they're not sure about the
script
now they did have a second script that
they were looking at a couple of months
ago but that got scrapped and apparently
this was an old script from years ago i
think dean devlin might have written it
but i don't know i'm sure that's just my
opinion um but they were looking at a
second scripture long
as they were sort of working on
developing brad wright's script
um that was never seriously to be made
but they were doing it as to like as a
comparison between the two
now according to my sources that i'm
talking to
there were a lot of rumors about
that maybe they need to look at somebody
else and fresh blood
now they've come to this conclusion
basically because during the meetings
and this would have been on
wednesday
lots of information was requested by
these cheek executives while they were
in the meetings and a lot of the
information was about star trek and
numbers
so they wanted demographics and things
like this about any information they
basically could find about star trek and
the different series of star trek over
the last couple of years
the only thing i can think of for that
is that they're using what kurtzman has
done and during star trek as the as a
model for what they want to maybe do
with stargate now i mean that from a
a production point of view not a story
an exception but but from a production
point of view
i'm going to get onto budgets in a
minute because that was also been
discussed
um
i'm not saying that brad wright is out
at all
um
so
much
don't panic calm down you're okay
um
i but
put it this way if everybody out of a
team of 20 people loved the script and
thought it was the way to go you'd be
concerned because someone's lying
somebody in that group is not going to
like it or think that maybe they should
try something else or fresh blood or
whatever they'll be probably people in
that room that maybe just don't like
brad i don't know it's this this is
these are human beings are talking about
it's going to be happening
the worry comes though is we need to
find out who those people are because at
the end of the day if it's like steve
wright is you know the chiefs executive
at mgm it's just got these concerns then
there's a problem because he's the guy
that's going to be making that final
decision
so i'm not surprised really that there
are voices i'm surprised
that they're still talking about it
because it seemed to me about two or
three weeks ago the brad rise project
was the one they were going to go with
when they scrapped the other one when
they were doing preliminary artwork and
stuff for
um presentations to to present to the
executives during these meetings for
this second mysterious script where they
scrapped it about three weeks ago i
thought well that's it then practice
projects in that's done
it's the only one they're talking about
they've looked at some of the artwork
and they've looked at the script and
they've had conversations about it and
they're still talking about whether they
think it's the right way to go or not
now
that is a concern because
doubts
are a concern once a project is black
and white and running then you know you
can everyone can get behind it
i was really confident two weeks ago
that this is going to happen i'm going
to happen really fast i was thinking you
know july
do you know when the 25th anniversary
happens we could actually get this green
lit we could we could start really
getting some really serious information
now
it doesn't seem
that it's a certain
i actually think that this this summit
and when the bosses have got involved
and they've kicked this plan around
might have put stargate back six months
to me it seems to me that they're asking
questions
that then the team is going to have to
go back and answer
they're going to have to go back maybe
even to brad wright and start having
conversations
and that basically means this is all
starting that process again where we
were at a point where we were i mean joe
milose said that though we were five
chevrons encoded but he said but the
sixth and seventh steps are the hardest
ones then the sixth and seventh steps
are the ones where the bosses get
involved and the chief executives get
involved and they start having to do
pitch meetings and somebody has to
actually write a damn check
now it seemed to me that a lot of the
work for the sixth chevron has been done
over the last two months or so
preliminary artwork a little bit of
storyboarding but when i say
storyboarding it's very preliminary it's
just stuff to like show the executives
in pitch meetings it's nothing that
would be ever used for actual proper
storyboarding in pre-production
um
but all that stuff does you know
convince the executives that yes let's
do this all that work seems to have been
done
if after these meetings they do decide
you know what
we don't like it it's back to square one
and that is a worry
and my worry is then that maybe they're
not as serious about pushing forwards
with stargate as we thought they were
and as the voices coming out of mgm said
they were
you know i've talked to you guys lots of
times now about the the people i speak
to and the rumors that run around the
mgm offices and and companies in and
around mgm and the voices were always
the amazon considered stargate to be one
of their top three priorities
but at the end of the day they're not
going to just greenlit
anything if they don't like it they're
not going to green light it
my poet didn't know
so
that really
really is a little bit concerning
but it's not the end of the world
because these are only concerns they're
only the boss is asking questions
it's not a no
and that is what i've been told by very
clearly is that after these meetings and
they basically spoke about stargate for
an entire afternoon apparently
um on wednesday that it was not a no
it's a no what do we do with this what
do we do that how many episodes should
we do what do we do um do what what
where do we put it um and apparently it
is going on amazon streaming it is going
on amazon prime
um those sort of conversations were had
conversations about budget were had and
i i'm not going to tell you a number
right now because i still need to
confirm something and i'll hopefully get
a video to you in a couple of days
but the number that is being bounced
around the number that's rumored for the
budget of this is less than they
currently spend on star trek discovery
starting discovery just so you know gets
between eight and eight and a half
million dollars um an episode to produce
so i did put a um poll up on the channel
and we'll see where it is live right now
on basically asking you guys if
s is basically star trek the
show that we should be comparing any new
stargate series to from a production
point of view should that be what
they're aiming for
at the moment 72 percent of you guys say
that yes start gate deserves the
financial backing and should get it
28 say that you know what brad wright
has done more with less before so you
know maybe the budget isn't as important
a couple of comments have said the story
is the most important thing
but i would argue that the budget is
equally as important as the story you
cannot tell a decent story without a
decent budget and you can't tell it
doesn't matter how big your budget is if
the store is crap
so you know we've got this these things
do go hand in hand
i would argue that if amazon were really
serious about this they should be aiming
to be better than star trek that star
trek should be the series they think
they're looking at
and that should be what they compare
themselves to and if they're serious
they should be thinking well that's the
sort of budget we should be looking at
and at the moment if these preliminary
numbers are true and this rumor about
this number is true
it's not it's a lot less
as a quick comparison somebody's
mentioned in the um in the in the
comments there there's a quick
comparison to think about how much money
some streaming um channels are spending
and 700 or 600 million dollars is being
spent on the first series of um the lord
of the rings series that's going to be
30 million an episode
which is just ridiculous money
the stargate number is much much lower
so let's have a quick look
it depends on how much cgi they plan
right so i will tell you a little bit
about the budgeting
they do a very preliminary budget for
this and what they will look at is
where
do they
plan
how many episodes they want
and i can tell you now
at the moment they're looking at 12
episodes
but with
brad wright has um if if assuming brad
rice project goes ahead branch right
will have a lot of leeway with that
he'll basically be given a budget and if
he wants to do 13 episodes or wants to
do 11 episodes and spend a bit more on
an episode
or he wants to
you know stretch that budget out a
little bit and get 13. it's because it's
streaming
you can do a series that you can
basically do around the story and you
don't have to do like a 22 episode
series to fit the network calendar sort
of thing you know we have we've got 22
weeks you've got to fill
um i think that's actually not bad
things means we don't get those filler
episodes that we're always used to and
so he can actually just have as many
episodes as the story requires which is
which is not bad
initially they're looking at 12. if it's
going on a streaming network though that
just seems to be the way of the world
now networks do 22 episodes streaming
services seem to do 10 12 episodes
don't know why just just do
um
so
we know
oh the other thing about how um
one of the things they did talk about
apparently on uh wednesday was they did
talk about roland emmerich's um
discussions that they had a few months
ago and roland emerick's whole idea
about the the the hard reboot was with
trolled out again apparently um but i
don't think that means anything to be
honest i think they just wanted to
see what he was saying so um but i don't
think anybody needs to be worried about
that we're not going to be getting the
the you know what they planned in 2015
for the roland emmerich trilogy hard
reboot it's not going to happen and
rolling memory because as good as said
because i mean he said in the interview
he did uh three or four months ago that
amazon and mgm are only really
interested in the tv audience and
they're the priority
we're not going to begin a hard reboot
no hard reboot
exactly
um so i went there they do so at the
moment it seems like again i'm going to
be getting a video out in this little
bit more detail but basically
to this six chevron
metaphor i keep using is when they do
think about budgets and things but it's
an initial budget so they think about
how long the filming run would be how
much cgi they think they're going to
need how big the cast is apparently
makes a massive difference
where they think they'll film it and
what those costs would be
apparently when they start a new series
like this the initial spending is
massive
um so actually the difference between
say producing 10 episodes and like 15
isn't is negligible to be honest
and because it's all those initial costs
they have um you know renting the sound
stage um setting up contracts with the
cgi companies that you know the
companies are going to produce the cgi
for them and all this sort of thing um
but putting all the actors on contracts
you know all these are massively
expensive and massively initial contacts
but then there are people that obviously
do this for a living they do it week in
week out they know exactly how to do it
so they will have a rough estimate
and then amazon as the customer will
basically come back and say what they're
willing to spend how much they're
willing to buy the series for
then when production starts the
negotiations start i mean there are
stories about people running around
literally going from office to office
begging for money um at some of these
studios you know when um
if you ever watch the um how they made
the home alone movie um it's it's
hilarious how they made it and you can't
believe it actually happens but
literally people was one person was
running around telling everyone that the
film was cancelled and then someone else
was running around behind in offices and
telling them there wasn't and there's
just oh it's just mad um it's on netflix
at the moment how they made um
the home loan movie it's fascinating
viewing of how the movies you know
really work or used to work at least
so yeah that's when all the negotiations
and the begging starts
um
but also then
this 12 episodes might just be the
initial run that could just be the first
half of the series you know you could go
on tend to do a longer series
potentially if the story did it if the
story made sense but again like you say
it's stretching the budget normally the
customer will say how this is how much
we're willing to spend based on what we
expect to actually
get viewing figures
once that budget is set though it tends
to be hard
and it tends to be very difficult to get
more money
producers tend to have to be quite
strict if you're here if you lose what
stories about brad wright talking about
how the initial script for stargate came
around emmerich was supposed to do the
tv series but he says he couldn't do it
because nine hundred thousand dollars an
episode back then was nothing like
enough to make this tv series he wanted
so he refused to do it brad wright was
really clever and he made that money
stretch
if the numbers i'm being told are true
he's gonna have to do that again and
he's gonna have to stretch it
um but i would argue maybe stargate is
more character driven
than star trek and maybe there would be
a lot less cgi in which case maybe the
cost is less so that's why the budget is
less we'll have to wait and see
apparently we've not got a name i asked
i did ask do they know has anybody seen
the script and apparently all the
scripts
i do know one guy who says he saw the
script
um but he didn't read it and but he saw
a copy
and he said he was very very tempted to
go and try and have a look but he did
tell me he says it is actually exactly
like we saw on joseph milose's at the um
titles blocked out
they are really really
being careful with the script and it
leaking out is
is not is not an option so um
you know
brad right or bust i think a lot of
people think that the the brad right's
gotta be the man
um
go back to vancouver yeah the only
problem with that is
there were conversations between mgm and
amazon
before while all this was going through
the um
the trade commission the federal trade
commission and apparently amazon did
make
um backroom agreements that any major
productions through mgm would be
produced in the united states
um at least for a certain period of time
now that doesn't include sort of like
when you do film in morocco and things
like that you know like
but any they would be based in the
united states
so if they
have to follow through with that or if
they can fudge it somehow and go back to
vancouver i'm absolutely certain brad
wright would love to
um and i think it would be very good for
people like amanda tapping um if they
get her back on board
but
this deal this agreement was apparently
to do with like
to loosen the wheels with the federal
trade commission to get them a little
bit more um on board with the with the
sale and because you know amazon isn't
popular than people
so
i think stargate mckay is the way to go
i think when we spoke last week
hi shelly how are you
um i think
everybody would love to see mckay come
back
so
guys that is where we're at at the
moment we're in a period of confusion
to recap very basically
oh i should tell you as well monday uh
the
12th of april monday just gone at the
11th sorry all they did was talk about
bond they had a james bond day
apparently and that's all they spoke
about all day so just to just to keep
you up to date that that's a very
obviously that is the probably the
biggest
piece of um
um
that's their most important project i
think that amazon are really really keen
to get on to boar
you mean they actually film at cheyenne
mountain they don't swear space
commander's basement
so um
it's not norad anymore cheyenne mountain
which i didn't know it's my space force
it's me sports go it's based so
um but yeah
that's about it then guys really i can
say
2001 space odyssey might be a tv series
who knew space paul's movie is
definitely coming back by the looks it
looks like we're getting another robocop
and war games has gone from rumor to
series project
um
apparently there are more summits and
meetings between amazon and mgm
executives planned for
late may
and that will again be at the mgm
headquarters in beverly hills
it's not a bad place to go for have
meetings
i imagine they've got pretty good
shopping um and their breaks if they
wanted to they earn enough
so again guys after the video um get in
the comments tell me exactly what you
think are you very disappointed by this
please remember these are only rumors
again um
you know this is just people from mgm
talking
and none of them were actually in the
room of these meetings so you know is
just from
their opinion that there's some pink
cases and the information about i'm like
them asking about stargate star trek
information and details to be talking to
the meetings very last minute that is
fact but other than that some of this is
rumor
um
i
promise you i can only say to you that
i'm less confident now than i was two
weeks ago
i was like 95 certain we were gonna get
stargate
greenlit this year a man now maybe
seventy percent certain
um i think
to be honest
i'm just a little bit worried that
the bosses have got involved now
and they're going to kick this project
to death
and
hey maybe it won't even happen
but
i can't see that
just maybe it won't happen with brad
right who knows
so
please get into the comments tell me
exactly what you think if you are new to
the channel please like subscribe hit
the bell notification it really helps us
out and you can become a fully fledged
side tracker you can consider hitting
the join button thanks very much guys
and
i'll see you very very soon with a video
all about the proposed budget for the
stargate series and if this video
disappointed you that video is going to
disappoint you even more
see you soon guys have a great day
how do i get that out throw up
[Music]
you